Молодь на ринку праці – на неї високий попит,
вона усім потрібна.
У кожному великому ярмарку вакансій
у Німеччині бере участь і Бундесвер - він прагне представити себе
як виграшного роботодавця.
Щороку в німецькій армії пропонується понад 26 тисяч робочих
та навчальних місць. Співбесіди
відбуваються прямо на місці. Конкуренція
за випускників шкіл велика.
Навіть ті, у кого раніше було обмаль шансів, нині можуть
розраховувати на успіх.
Я також мав співбесіду. Щодо місця солдата.
Це виявилося цікаво, та й мій дядько
також служить. Я б сказав, він надихнув мене на це,
я навіть був у нього на роботі - подивитися,
як це відбувається.
Друг наштовхнув мене на ідею, що якщо хочеться вивчати медицину
- а для чого потрібен дуже високий середній бал -
то можна також спробувати зробити це в армії.
Я б воліла вивчати медицину у звичайному виші,
але не думаю, що мого балу вистачить.
Бундесвер пропонує величезний вибір
різноманітних професій та навчальних курсів.
Але про це небагато кому відомо.
Гадаю, не так складно активніше
розповідати про розмаїття наших можливостей, щоб зацікавлені
могли, так мовити, наочно це побачити.
Переконаний, що у нас практично до кожного горщика
знайдеться підходяща покришка.
Нестача молодих кадрів - загальна проблема на ринку праці.
У Бундесвері сподіваються, що менш кваліфікованих пошуківців зможуть належним чином довчити,
аби поліпшити їхні професійні та особисті якості.
Природжені таланти знайти складно.
Наші виклики такі ж, що й у приватній економіці:
бракує передусім фахівців природничо-технічних спеціальностей.
Так, нам украй потрібні ай-ті фахівці, медики.
Ми шукаємо також людей, які увійшли б до лав
пожежного підрозділу Бундесверу.
Ті ж, хто вирішить залишитися в армії довше, ніж на 11 місяців,
мають бути готовими й до закордонних операцій.
Багато молодих людей про це мають лише приблизне уявлення.
Я точно не знаю, чи це правильно з моральної точки зору,
якщо я буду, так би мовити, підтримувати війну.
Але з іншого боку моя спеціальність –
медицина, тому я буду допомагати людям, тобто невинним людям.
Насправді після закінчення школи я все-одно хотіла б
ще поїхати за кордон на семестр або загалом на навчання,
тому з цим в мене проблем немає. Але я боюся,
чи витримаю це психологічно.
Залучення молодих кадрів обходиться Бундесверу
в копієчку. Запуск телесеріалу
на власному ютьюбканалі коштувало збройним силам ФРН
майже вісім мільйонів євро.
Серіал "12 рекрутів" про службу в Бундесвері
має мільйонні перегляди, але проблему
пошуку молодих кадрів це поки
не вирішило.